[Musique]
tous et bienvenue dans on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge aujourd'hui elle a
décidé de vous emmener faire un petit
tour à la fraîche dans les halls de la
réunion puisqu'on se trouve à la plaine
des palmistes alors certes cette
fraîcheur nous permet parfois de sortir
des chaleurs débat l'île de la réunion
mais elle est également très propice à
un petit fruit rouge emblématique des
auteurs de la réunion du goyavier et ça
tombe bien puisque une auto de la
semaine sylvie léger est une adepte de
ce fruit cal cultive et qu'elle
transforme et c'est précisément ce qu on
vous emmène découvrir pour ce nouveau
mur allait sortir
[Musique]
alors en ligne oui
bonjour
ça va arriver où je te dérange pas non
oui super forme dernièrement j'ai aux
animaux pour mieux rejoindre peut-être
oui vous
bonjour je fais la bise wii
va bien oui toi moi ça va
se savoir oui
mais ce que tu peux nous en dire un peu
plus on se trouve voilà vous trouvez
dans la plaine des palmistes et là c'est
mon exploitation c'est sûr à côté de la
cascade biberon et donc qui s'appelle au
club la cascade du beau et pour résumer
ben je suis éleveur de volailles ensuite
je suis je fais aussi du maraîchage
ensuite je suis productrice de goyavier
et je fais de la transformation en
goyaviers je veillais par la confiture
pas et cetera ensuite j'ai une table
d'hôtes oui qu'est ce que tu en penses y
ont fini de nourrir ses ses canards et
ses oies et après tu m'emmènes faire un
petit tour
par derrière on peut trouver des
goyaviers voilà
[Musique]
et puis d'aller défaisant
oui c'est pas pour la dame seule non non
non non non il ne parle pas il ne fait
pas que crime mais il me fait comprendre
qu'une chose quoi comment est ce qu'il
fait quand il n'est pas content par
exemple si je suis pas las est en fait
continue à pas le voir mais après ils
essayent de me b kitsch et quand tu
reviens vite fait la fête tout ça sera
non mais regardez un très bon observé là
c'est vrai si on regarde bien on le
regarde moi tu vois que n'en avait pas
vu depuis deux jours là
[Musique]
donc là je t'emmène derrière donc c'est
là où il ya le champ de goyavier avec un
sentier botanique est en train d'être
mis en place donc là on peut voir on lie
alma au l'abaya lebron qui a plus de 100
ans ensuite il ya des orchidées il ya le
bois joli coeur donc plus d'une
cinquantaine défense endémiques de la
réunion sur ton terrain si tu dis ouais
et tout ça c'est toi qu'à planter ou
c'était là avant que non j'ai repris ici
en 2008 je me suis ici on pouvait pas
passer c'était une forêt amazonienne de
goyavier et donc avec les anciens
sentiers depuis mes anciens et du coup
bah moi je me suis lancé dans le le truc
enfin de remettre en valeur se sente ce
champ de goyaviers qu'est ce que tu
proposes aux gens qu'ils viennent cette
assemblée gens qui viennent manger à
table tête ils ont la cueillette de
goyavier d'accord y compris dans le ils
viennent manger forcément ils peuvent
venir se balader récupérer autant il est
l'équivalent d'un oui mais il ya le prix
du kilo le sosie 10 euros 8 euros c'est
assez intimiste
parce que je l'accueille pas les gens
par bus je sais vraiment et vient à
table d'hôte et après il vient de
prendre pour avoir le plaisir de venir
chercher des goyaviers donc tu m'emmènes
faire un tour place
[Musique]
il ya deux ans mais son beau
dans cette formation là
on voit bien la cascade du bon ouais
d'où le nom de ta ferme auberge là pour
le coup là je comprends coeur de la
cascade biberon on peut importe on se
trouve sur le terrain on a toujours un
magnifique point de vue sur la casquette
bima
ça me fait croire
mon pare balles ça c'est une activité
que tu proposes hâter un nom mais ma mon
activité même pour le ramassage des
goyaviers ces bains peu je suis dans
dans une coopérative la coopérative
ananas et là on parle par tonne donc bon
morceau
par morceau cette année je pense que
j'ai dû faire de 2,5 à peu près d'un
parent se donne cinq tout seul j'imagine
c'est l'aide de la famille pour ramasser
puis après on livre à la coop ananas et
après eux mêmes soient ces
transformateurs ou qui viennent chercher
à la copa nasri goyaviers bon bah ouais
d'apparemment on est loin du compte a
donc intérêt à se mettre au boulot
moi je te dis à ce rythme là on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge
une petite info il ya trois sortes de
goya vie un rouge clair
donc c'est le goyavier fraises
ensuite celui qu'on voit par exemple
comme l'apa et qui grandit jusqu'en haut
c'est goyavier sabine c'est le
traditionnel voilà et ensuite la loterie
yaris et il n'y avait pas
[Musique]
le cadre est juste magnifique
d'après lui quoi pour se mêler de faire
on va me gâcher alors ça c'est quelque
chose d'original du vendredi honnêtement
c'est la première fois que j'entends
parler de ça ça s'est bien passé dans
s'était fait en garde pour soi à choisir
la plaine je dis ce que je veux dire
c'est les anciens qui faisait du vin de
paille aviez comme la planète palmer ça
a été labellisé village créole donc il
fallait trouver un thème crinière avec
du code aviez c'est là on a dû passer
est ce que ça existe eu on avait dit au
début du civet coq au vin qu y avait
donc ben moi j'ai h et j'ai fait
l'atelier en faisant ce truc à omaha au
début bon ben c'était hyper sucre et
puis après on fait du temps à trouver la
bonne dose et du coup maintenant c'est
le poulet aux vins n'y avait pas le ciri
parce que ça va encore donc en fait
c'est vraiment ta recette c'est dire que
c'est quasiment le seul endroit à l'île
de la réunion on peut venir déguster à
cimescaut covan goyavier c'est chez toi
quand même fait nous mêmes le vin donc
toi même le vent
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
bon alors cv il en est où ça me suivez
alors ce fameux 6 v c'est plutôt le
poulet aux vagues goyavier et les au feu
et concrètement alors ça se passe
comment si on veut faire son propre vin
mes valises en vous preniez une quantité
pas son petit peu moins de 2 kg et faut
500 g de sucre et il faut mettre dans un
bac alimentaire ou un fou et un peu de
vous laisser fermenter et une fois qu'on
a fait tout ça est ce que c est ce que
ça se goûte
tu peux pas commencer à oui oui un petit
peu pour commencer alors déjà de l'odeur
est particulière
ça qu'il s'est passé je trouve plus
presque un arrière-goût de cidre je
trouve donc du coup effectivement je
vois que tu as des bouteilles de vin là
derrière toi mais pas que je crois qu'il
ya de la gelée la confiture et tout ça
fait maison est d'accord à l'affût d'un
traditionnel sa traditionnelle que c'est
fait à la traditionnelle or la pâte
c'est comme des pâtes de fruits voilà et
ensuite le bel a juré les la barre
ouais donc là on retrouve un échantillon
exhaustif de tout ce que tu de tout ce
qu'il est possible finalement d'acheter
ici quoi ouais voilà mais là j'ai pas
encore vu mais étiquette je vais prendre
mon petit jeu les alors moi j'aime bien
tout ce qui est quand même je sais que
lui il aime bien tout ce qui rompt ça
c'est pour lui ça va là je te l'offre
pour le déficit pas de ça avec du
fromage des plaines avec du fromage des
modes apparemment c'est très serré
[Musique]
la data
dai
la banane danone
l'anaé
là
tu disais tout à l'heure on parler de
tes relations avec la commune de la
plaine des palmistes parce que tu peux
m'en dire un petit peu plus c'est une
couille avis qui l'emportent sur la
plaine et comme si très recherchée
maintenant donc du coup il ya eu des
prises de conscience quoi pourtant c'est
une peste végétale oui mais comme je le
dis la peste végétale oui mais s'ils ont
la maîtrise je dirais comme nous les
producteurs on va pas laisser en friche
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'en coupant
en ayant une certaine hauteur en la
maîtrisant on gagne un peu plus de
rendement est l'intérêt de goyave essaie
de ramasser le plus de goyavier donc à
mary aussi
derrière nous pour ça il ya la fête des
goyaviers déjà la wii 2 puis a oscillé
marché noël où les marchés de aux fleurs
mais il à la fête même que je ne rate
pas c'est la fête des goyaviers tu
m'étonnes tu as l'air bien être
passionné pour passer à côté de l'autre
et les veines oui
c'est vraiment délicieux je suis sûr que
tu regrettes d'avoir les mains privées
tout cela
une fois qu'on aura fini de se régaler
avec ce repas ou est ce que tu proposes
de nous emmener
les boues
[Musique]
ennahda
la taille
ah la la
la nasa
alors après cette découverte culinaire
délicieuse qu'on doit sylvie on se
retrouve ici à la forêt de bébour ou
bien j'aimerais bien apprendre un petit
peu plus sur toi mais avant ça qu'est ce
que tu nous conseille comme activité ici
à la plaine des palmistes une fois qu'on
a quitté la table donc ben je propose
demain comme la ici l'endroit que
j'affectionne c'est la forêt de bébour
où on peut venir se reposer là dessus on
a saisi s'allonger dormir sur la table
oui voilà ça vous sa table ensuite il ya
des activités comme accro plein ensuite
il ya tout ce qui est bien randonnée
donc en sortant de bébour
il ya un trou de fer
on pourrait aller c'est une balade assez
facile ensuite on peut aller jusqu'au
gîte de bélouve la ferme auberge
depuis qu il existe depuis qu'umberto
parce que tu as raconté cela la ferme
auberge gel depuis 2012 mais sinon
l'entreprise même depuis 2008 depuis
janvier 2008 où j'ai repris
l'exploitation de mon père qui a pris sa
retraite commencez tout ce qui est
poulet le maraîchage et puis je me suis
lancée dans le col aviez ce que j'avais
une forêt comme j'habitais tout à
l'heure j'étais bien des gens voient la
place donc c'était dommage de paris et
puis je me suis lancée dans la confiture
la gelée et puis là j'ai fait des foires
et je me suis fait connaître et
c'est pas facile je suis pas facile de
faire le choix de deux
agricultrices des chefs d'exploitation
pas facile du tout et je suis fier de ce
que je suis devenu aujourd'hui quand tu
regarde vers l'avenir bonnes raisons
d'avoir le sourire oui oui oui oui je
veux dire gg je joue et je vois mon
avenir
ensoleillé très ensoleillée ça va
voilà oui bah tu sais quoi aujourd'hui
de quitter son joli présage soleil qui
illumine son visage
oui
je te remercie pour tous à très bientôt
et après je te donnerai mon plein de
bonnes choses merci beaucoup au revoir
[Musique]
la datar
la dalle
la la la voilà comment se termine cet
épisode
alors je sais pas pour vous mais moi
j'ai été particulièrement touchée par un
parent sylvie et par l'investissement
qui met dans son entreprise alors si
vous voulez une rencontre particulière
vraiment et partager un peu de temps
avec un personnage est touchant c'est
comme ça que je vais voilà c'est comme
ça que je la décris retouchant moi je
vous invite à venir non seulement pour
ça mais également pour l'aspect un
original de sa cuisine alors en ce qui
me concerne on se retrouve très vite sur
les routes de la réunion alors à plus
il passé
[Musique]